oh my goodness I am so excited you guys
today we are going to be unboxing
something very very exciting right here
here it is check it out check it out
check it out this is the LG OLED Evo G3
TV and as you can see here I have a very
empty wall and a very empty TV stand
which is going to be perfect to put this
on a huge thank you to LG for partnering
with me on this video so let's get this
all unboxed and set up
well I think that's our control
thank you instructions some batteries
and a cable
which looks like we're just gonna lift
this up
[Music]
so we have the TV stand here and this is
actually sold separately so if you do
want to mount this it does come with
this wall mount here if you do want to
mount this TV with this one wall design
it can get so incredibly close to the
wall that it just looks so seamless and
beautiful but I like putting my TVs on
stands
look at that
beautiful the installation of the stand
actually looks super easy we basically
just have to clip it in and add a few
screws and we're good to go
oh
that is so satisfying
wow it looks really good
so there's a few reasons why I was so
excited to check out this Evo G3 now the
panel is a 3840 by 2164k Ultra HD self
lit OLED that supports Dolby vision and
hdr10 allowing for brightness of over
2100 nits 10 bit color depth and 100
color volume for amazing details and
color the Evo G3 is powered by LG's
Alpha 9 AI processor which Powers the
native 120 hertz refresh rate and the AI
Tech that automatically adjusts the
brightness levels picture and sound
volume depending upon what you're
watching this processor also Powers the
brightness booster Max feature which
produces a 70 Brighter Image compared to
non-olette Evo models for high contrast
picture quality even in really well-lit
rooms like this oh my goodness this is
so wild seeing this on such a huge
display I mean I was editing this on my
computer so actually seeing this in
person
it feels like I'm actually back in the
Maldives oh I miss it oh my gosh like
even the viewing angles like it feels
like like I'm flying above the ocean
right now whoa okay whoa let's see what
it sounds like
oh yeah
it sounds good too something else that
was super impressive is the sound
quality I love the automatic volume
adjustment because a lot of times I'm
watching a lot of these shows and
sometimes the voices are super low and
then you have these high action scenes
and it's really cool because it makes
all of those quiet parts so much easier
to hear and the loud Parts not as loud
now with the OLED Evo G3 you're also
getting the latest version of thin Q Ai
and the newly added webos 23 for
browsing content quick cards for
organizing apps a magic remote for easy
navigation along with a five-year panel
warranty I don't know if you guys are
like me but I really don't watch a lot
of traditional cable television like
live TV I do have it just because it
kind of came with my internet package
and like when and my family comes to
visit they sometimes like to watch the
local news so we keep it just for the
sake of keeping the peace but I don't
really watch it that often so I'm
downloading a bunch of the apps and I
really love this web OS 23 interface
because it gives you access to all of
these great apps and you don't actually
need to have a traditional TV service so
I'm hyped about that this is fast whoa
this is really Speedy I'm so used to my
old TV which it felt a little laggy like
every time I would like scroll this is
so fast in addition to Dolby vision and
HDR 10 support the LG OLED Evo G3 also
has filmmaker mode and dynamic tone
mapping Pro this really lets you see the
content the way that the Creator
intended and you can get incredible
contrast in every scenario now as you
know I am very obsessed with playing
video games so for me personally I need
a TV that is going to be Top Notch for
gaming and the LG OLED Evo G3 is
actually optimized as a gaming TV it has
a less than point one millisecond
response time which is so crazy fast
plus it supports Nvidia g-sync and
freesync premium for Smooth hair free
gameplay to minimize any distractions
while I'm in the zone so when I click
into the settings this will
automatically take you into game mode
when you switch to the console so you
can see we have our frames per second we
have a black stabilizer you can turn on
and off low latency and I like this as
well it has a dark room mode so you can
choose various levels on or off you also
could have a multi-view which I think is
pretty awesome so if you want to play
games and watch TV or YouTube at the
same time or even watch a live stream
this mode is pretty awesome because you
can basically be playing video games and
watching content on the other side
there's also different modes too so you
can change this to be a different type
of multi-view instead of side by side
you can also do the picture in picture
so depending upon what type of view you
want you have that flexibility so when
you go into the game Optimizer this
gives you some more settings to further
optimize your gameplay depending upon
what game you you're playing and the
room settings that you have so it's
really exciting that you can go through
and customize all of these this lets you
further improve your gameplay depending
upon what game you're playing it's
pretty cool that you're able to do this
especially if you're the type of person
that plays a lot of different genres of
video games this will let you fine-tune
to whatever game you happen to be
playing at that time I also just cannot
get over how bright and colorful this TV
is and with the enhanced contrast even
darker games come through very clearly
overall I'm super stoked on the LG OLED
Evo G3 I'm gonna put a link in the
description where you can find more info
and you can also search LG OLED to learn
more about its Journey during the past
10 years as 2023 marks the 10th
consecutive year of LG and OLED TV
making if you have any questions feel
free to leave them in the comments below
and thank you guys so much for watching
do subscribe if you haven't already and
be sure to hit the Bell to be notified
when I post new videos and I will see
you guys in the next one I'm gonna go
play some games now